welcome to this video playing Francisco
G from the US and let's see if I can
actually play a decent game I played
some warm-up games and I really
recognize that I'm far too tired to play
it to play but I don't have any videos
on on on my backlog and I'd like to keep
up this 3 videos a day routine so um
let's see if I manage to to do something
decent am ok with the Catalan closed
Catalan term this is well known type of
position that is normally quite tricky
for black let's see yeah my default many
good news actually the position is
tricky because I have those active nodes
night f5 or so one point let's let's
just do that my warmup games i was
playing even slower than usual so on i
try to play a bit quicker especially if
the opponent seems to play frankly
speaking better just bad moves and plays
on time let's let's just try to be a bit
quicker in that case ok
a for securing this for the moment maybe
there was something more powerful
already it's very likely actually
because l'exposition already looks quite
suspicious to me the night on f5 is
especially strong ok I'd like to get out
of this is possible check done there's
even night x g7 as a possible idea cake
King takes an takuna five this might be
might be dangerous really ok I'll just
try to get to g5
and I'm getting out of this pin so that
maybe 96 at some point is possible it
there would be a kind of self pin though
on the deef also probably not 96 in the
near future but Queen g5 would be quite
nice getting the Queen near the King in
a very threatening threatening fashion
yeah it's not easy at all for black to
to play
night you form hmm yeah that's not it's
not really helping him so much more than
one good reply Nick Queen D for this may
be Knight f6 but can go to e 30 a2m yeah
it's not he's not moving yeah it's it's
very average very difficult to play yeah
well I thought Queen g5 but maybe
there's an 94
yeah okay but then I can go to h form
okay probably if this is the right one
anyway okay well here that's night h6
but this King King h8 possible so just
drop back threatening Bishop f6 keeping
the pressure on yeah well if I take yeah
it's a very good very good position
takes Queen takes Knight h6 takes Bishop
f6 you can give this check but yeah
that's a very nice position hmm
all-rookie one just keeping the pressure
on
a rookie one
also very good okay how to how to decide
check King a jade neither 7ss an
outright win and now I can just take and
take with the bishop to check try to use
his weakened king I didn't really see
that v3 hangs check this is a shame
ready hmm okay yeah this wasn't the best
way to play pretty sure yeah maybe I
should have played rookie one I mean
maybe this is still good for white but
this wasn't the best best possible
continuation that's quite a quite clear
yeah threatening f5
yeah my king my king is some getting
getting a king position is getting a bit
suspicious
oh I had this f5 f5 g-form
at least I'm not hopelessly behind on
the clock the only positive I mean the
game should have been over already her
name but I let it let it slip and he
could have taken on b3 even this would
happen potentially even even more of a
problem yeah it doesn't really help him
let's see maybe I can actually fix his
pawns a bit check okay i'm at least i'm
not mated
threatening queen bee three so this
those sideways checks sometimes quite
rakim check
not sure I really want to trade check
not before to c6 could be something
though check time morning hmm ok let's
take the two pawns black resigned yeah
and the Jeep on is actually a very
strong just it just pulls through right
okay can go to see one but advocates i
think it's it's it's lost now yeah at
least a bit of luck in this game I mean
lucky and I really I'll I didn't let him
our to me the position was very good
after after the opening around here
that's or you can all you can wish for
but so the computer is not so
enthusiastic okay with the computers a
notoriously good to fender it wants to
play rook see you one actually Roxy one
yeah okay but this is quite amazing that
this really doesn't met anything it
looks very nice exactly the church is
good just good I mean I can I probably
should go to g1 this really is Oh Bishop
g7 wins for black yeah
quite quite quite nice quite nice if I
take check checkmate yo and i have no
move I can play this move and any place
this ugly f6 but ugly but I'm ugly but
winning winning a piece to 19 f5 and I
g5 check this is what you played and
this is just nothing nothing special and
then he attacked any blundered in the
end game so it's probably quite Jewish
check check yeah auntie em there's
something better probably it doesn't
really need to allow that but here just
can easily happen and let's chat so
should be it wrong yeah just probably to
e7 right but is it a draw something like
this yeah you can play g4 yeah and this
this is really a draw yeah so but still
I mean this position must be must be
good for a while I cannot you cannot
really believe that so Queen a for a
foursome with Lena 22 it's actually
winning outright the computer says
interesting yeah wow this is a very very
strong move I mean queen g5 is a threat
and they're basically with a for lost
the tempo and one problem is that i'm
also threatening to take let's say a
place that I can just take here and wins
cute okay i hope you liked it thanks for
watching